so Justin Bieber I've done about seven
of these shows have not talked about
Bieber yet believe it or not so let's do
it
anyway I just want to say he's pissed at
me yeah oh then I haven't hit on the guy
I haven't helped him trend on Twitter
yet but we're gonna do it right here
right now so he was in Amsterdam he was
doing a little European tour and he
stopped by the end Frank House I'm sure
you guys have all heard this already
he signed the guestbook and I want to
get the quote correctly so I'm going to
read it to you
he wrote truly inspiring to be able to
come here and was a great girl hopefully
she would have been a belieber he also
tweeted that it was a chill day in
Amsterdam that day not chilly chill it
was a cool day
alright so Justin Bieber he wants an
Frank
who died in the Holocaust everyone knows
the story to be a belieber is this yeah
well she was a great girl a great girl I
mean here's this kid finally he screwed
everything up the last two months have
been you know a PR nightmare for this
kid yeah he's finally doing something
right okay he's in Amsterdam he's gonna
go to the mne screws at all right
something seemingly selfless and just Oh
beliebers are like tweeting we don't
even know who she is anyway why is
everybody upset it's like such an
opportunity to educate his 387 million
Twitter followers before I get let you
jump in on this and so as the PR guy do
you think there's any chance that this
was in calculating because on one hand
you know nothing he does is calculated
he's a 19 year old kid who I think is I
look at this a business okay this is a
what 50 75 million dollar a year
business and I've said it before gonna
say it publicly I don't think he's
getting good advice I think this kid
thinks he knows it all and I think a
little humility a little respect and I
think the people who are running his
life has managers and his publicist Oh
him to sort of tell him the way the
world works that dude
don't know it all at 19:30 and respected
the kids not have it anymore Aaron Foley
here's the thing
he is like an he's an entourage well
first of all let me back up it was a
great girl
that's where my head popped off and I've
been trying to put it back all day icon
a hero no a great girl that's what you
say to like Selena Gomez when they break
up like that she was a great girl thank
Anne Frank then you think you see all
these reports where he's like you know
his entourage is like you know forty
deep but he's got guards and you would
assume he has a handler
you know so when Justin Bieber writes
that it's totally fine when he when he
writes that someone right behind him
crosses out a couple these words instead
of hopefully it should have been a
believer hopefully I hoped she would
have been rescued a little little white
out for a tional stories add some words
I mean like like hire a handler what are
the part that I'm kind of fascinated
with this is that the the people at the
Anne Frank House they actually posted
what he wrote on Facebook and they are
backing it with no they're not saying
that it was
when's the last time anybody talked to
money in French okay little attention
right now and I think it is calling you
know the good news is yeah that it is
calling attention to something and I
think last week was the week of
remembrance for the Holocaust yeah and I
think it is important that we don't
forget and and my parents you know we're
a generation that lived through that I
grew up after it certainly you know now
part kids today are very detached
something that happened last week was
ancient history and his kids so it's
really important that we remind people
that something this heinous existed in
our lifetimes essentially is that the
solar
right that's the only good that he is
thinking like Anne Frank's is gonna be
like holed up in the attic with iTunes
like rocking out to Justin Bieber while
the Nazis are walking down the street
it's just it's so inconceivable yeah
having a chill day yeah I'm going to a
Holocaust Remembrance it was a great
dress that now all of our news is
couched in celebrity so you got Bieber
and Anne Frank I mean I can't even
believe I just said that in a sentence
then you got the white house literally
answering questions this week about
jay-z and Beyonce going to keep but we
got Dennis Rodman who just announced
he's going back to North Korea is this
really the only way we can get to young
people by attaching celebrity to every
important story yes yeah listen you know
I wrote this piece on HuffPo and I was
called culture of crisis and it's why
the news has sort of morphed into this
crap that we have now okay we've been at
war for 10 years never in the history of
our country would you ever be at war and
turn on the evening news or turn a
newspaper and the war not be a
front-page story yeah you can go through
the New York Times the LA Times there
will be not one article on any given day
about the war yeah yeah not only the war
are the longest war that America has
ever been in so this is not just some
little world and it used to be that the
media you know all these respected news
organizations would give you a little
meat a little vegetable maybe if you're
good you get a little dessert at the end
now there really is a more desert equals
better rating so you get all dessert now
yeah start
fingers crossed of his downward spiral
meltdown yeah we all love to see at
least I do take that Bieber your spiral
downward downfall is a common all right
let's move on we're gonna get the you're
gonna get them after you you know when
those little suckers get mad they get
mad no hash tag belieber I love all of
you people you're wonderful keep up the
good work one direction you're all
fantastic everything
Lenovo's calm is the official outfitter
of the Reuben report I want to put you
in this slim fit shirt go to bonobos
calm enter code TRR 2-0 for 20% off your
next purchase